it's a historic election in more ways
than one
it's the first time chileans will have a
say in who will write a new constitution
a document that will determine the
country's economic political
and social roadmap
gloria perez and her husband believe
it's no small feat
this will define our future that's why
this day is so special
in order to make the necessary changes
the social changes
that we've been waiting for for so long
chileans are also electing mayors
governors and city council members
but the constitutional vote is regarded
as the most significant
the current constitution written 40
years ago under the augusto pinochet
dictatorship
is regarded by a great many as
illegitimate
and the source of many of chile's ills
for the first time anywhere in the world
50
of delegates to a constitutional
convention will be women
17 of the 155 delegates will also
represent chile's indigenous people
their existence isn't even recognized in
the current constitution
and another first to prevent long lines
because of the pandemic
the election is taking place over two
rather than one day
that means these votes won't be counted
until sunday the end of the second day
in the meantime these bins will be taped
completely and
covered with seals that according to
electoral authorities
will break if anybody tries to tamper
with the votes
and then they will be taken to a special
security area and kept under guard by
the army
even so a lot of people don't trust the
system
that's why daniel who works in front of
his designated polling station
is staying out for nowhere
i can't wait to vote but tomorrow all of
us will go tomorrow because we've seen
in many countries that when they leave
the votes overnight
someone changes them while chile doesn't
have a reputation for vote tampering
it's a reflection of how discredited
political institutions
and politicians have become in this
country
where millions are waiting for a new
constitution to prioritize the social
rights of the majority
rather than the privileges of a minority
lucian newman al jazeera santiago